[موسيقى]
يعتبر سرطان البروستات هو اشهر الاورام
التي تصيب الرجال فوق سن ال 50 عاما ولذلك
يجب على كل رجل فوق هذا السن ان يفعل
الثانويه لهذا المرض طبق للاحصاءات التي
اجريت في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يصيب
هذا المرض حوالي ما نسبته 1% من تعداد
السكان وهو رقم يعتبر عالي سكانيه
لا توجد اعراض بالنسبه لهذا المرض الخبيث
ولذلك يجب على كل راجل فوق سن ال 50 ان
يكون باجراء الفحص ثانويه
[موسيقى]
يتم التشخيص النهائي بالنسبه للاورام
البروستات باستخدام الاشعه المقطعيه
والرنين المغناطيسي وذلك بعد اخذ عينه من
البروستات
يعتمد علاج مرضى سرطان البروستات على عمر
المريض وحالته الصحيه العامه وكذلك يعتمد
على مرحله انتشار هذا المرض سواء كان
مازال داخل البروستات او خرج منها الشيء
الثالث هو مرحله شراسه هذا المرض اذا ان
بعض هذه الاوراق بتكون قليله الشراسه
وبالتالي يكون علاجها مختلف عن الامراض
السريعه الانتشار
الاخير وهو الاهم وتقبل المريض للعلاج
ومضاعفاته سواء كان هذا العلاج جراحيا ام
اشعاعيا او الهرمونات
[موسيقى]